In the relation x is
equal to y squared plus 3,
can y be represented as a
mathematical function of x?
So the way they've
written it, x is
being represented as a
mathematical function of y.
We could even say that
x as a function of y
is equal to y squared plus 3.
Now, let's see if we
can do it the other way
around, if we can represent
y as a function of x.
So one way you could
think about it is you
could essentially try
to solve for y here.
So let's do that.
So I have x is equal
to y squared plus 3.
Subtract 3 from both
sides, you get x minus 3
is equal to y squared.
Now, the next step is going
to be tricky, x minus 3
is equal to y squared.
So y could be equal to-- and I'm
just going to swap the sides.
y could be equal to-- if we take
the square root of both sides,
it could be the positive
square root of x minus 3,
or it could be the
negative square root.
Or y could be the negative
square root of x minus 3.
If you don't believe me,
square both sides of this.
You'll get y squared
is equal to x minus 3.
Square both sides
of this, you're
going to get y squared
is equal to-- well,
the negative squared is just
going to be a positive 1.
And you're going to get y
squared is equal to x minus 3.
So this is a situation
here where for a given x,
you could actually
have 2 y-values.
Let me show you.
Let me attempt to
sketch this graph.
So let's say this is our y-axis.
I guess I could call
it this relation.
This is our x-axis.
And this right over here,
y is a positive square root
of x minus 3.
That's going to look like this.
So if this is x is equal to 3,
it's going to look like this.
That's y is equal to the
positive square root of x
minus 3.
And this over here, y is equal
to the negative square root
of x minus 3, is going to
look something like this.
I should make it a little
bit more symmetric looking,
because it's going to
essentially be the mirror
image if you flip
over the x-axis.
So it's going to look
something like this-- y is
equal to the negative
square root of x minus 3.
And this right over here,
this relationship cannot be--
this right over here
is not a function of x.
In order to be a function
of x, for a given x
it has to map to exactly
one value for the function.
But here you see it's mapping
to two values of the function.
So, for example, let's say
we take x is equal to 4.
So x equals 4 could get
us to y is equal to 1.
4 minus 3 is 1.
Take the positive square
root, it could be 1.
Or you could have x equals 4,
and y is equal to negative 1.
So you can't have
this situation.
If you were making a table
x and y as a function of x,
you can't have x is equal to 4.
And at one point it equals 1.
And then in another
interpretation of it,
when x is equal to 4,
you get to negative 1.
You can't have one input
mapping to two outputs
and still be a function.
So in this case, the relation
cannot-- for this relation,
y cannot be represented as a
mathematical function of x.